if that's sort of uh the best of
totalitarian government can do
um you know Paid Family Leave is just
not going to move the needle Scott do
you have you found any places where
these policies either seem to work or or
they kind of pay for themselves or or
something
uh so I thought Liz's uh article did a
great job summarizing the evidence
um I've I've tended to sort of
look to some of the more pronatalist
folks out there who
um you know would love to find policies
that would move the Needle and to sort
of see what they say so uh I think now
as the time and the uh the conversation
that that we ring the bell and invoke
lymanstone he had a long Twitter
response which is kind of his bonus
operandi uh to Liz's original piece when
it came out and what was interesting
about it was uh to me was that he
claimed first of all that that 99 of uh
the well first that Liz ignored the
programs that work uh was the first one
second that 99 of what's tried uh is to
meager uh to have any impact
um so I guess he's saying Liz missed the
one percent uh uh of studies and then
third that um you know as an example of
something
that to be clear he didn't endorse um uh
but something that could move the needle
was in Romania uh you know where they
outlawed birth control and abortion for
uh
yeah this was under chochesko so yeah at
the peak of chuchisca's uh glorious
Powers Yeah so you know for more than a
decade outlawing uh birth control and
abortion from for most of the population
um and as far as I could tell the the
claim was that uh maybe in the long run
they increased the total fertility rate
by half a child
um so you know if that's uh if that's
sort of uh the best a totalitarian
government can do
um you know Paid Family Leave is just
not going to move the needle uh you know
I think Liz quotes somebody is saying
like the amounts we're talking about
versus how much it costs to raise a kid
you know the idea that a three thousand
dollar uh child tax credit instead of a
two thousand dollar child tax credit uh
is gonna suddenly uh reverse the trends
um just doesn't make any sense to me
yeah and I I guess there's that issue of
like even if it was thirty thousand
dollars I mean what
um
you know and I I don't mean to put you
guys individually on the spot but you
know what would it take to put you in
the position of having more kids and Liz
you're actually you you have one child
and you're pregnant with your second
um you know what would it take for you
to uh you know to have triplets or
something like that and I mean I don't
think there's any amount of money that
would be would make me have more kids
than I than I otherwise wanted to and I
think that's that's the big problem with
a lot of these most people these aren't
decisions that you can buy you know
these are deeply based on deeply held
beliefs and and values and they're not
the kind of thing that you can easily
Sway With a little more money they have
shown you know to be fair they have
shown that like some of these policies
can change the timing of kids they can
make people have kids sooner but not
necessarily have more
um and you know they get there are some
people that some policies might make
convinced you know it's not like
literally they don't work on anybody
like I'm sure that you know there are
families that might have an extricate if
they got free child care but it's just
not ever enough to make to make any sort
of difference except for on the margins
you know like it's not it's not making
any wide scale difference I know uh I I
believe this was my birth announcement I
was born in 1963 so it was the end of
the baby boom uh but um it it the birth
announcement it had a picture of the
baby with a diaper and a stamp on the
diaper saying another tax deduction
which is kind of you know a kind of
early Nautilus kind of policy right
um and but it I don't think my parents
took seriously you know the cost of
children or how much money they might
get out of it and I know in my own
experience and again you know we you
know we can't mistake this for kind of
data or or random controlled studies or
anything like that but the idea that you
would be able to pay people to have more
kids it's
it seems kind of
um you know it's it's just not going to
work and and Liz in your piece you do
point to a number of places where it
shows the timing of children uh you know
changed uh in some of these studies but
it really did not increase the overall
amount Scott what um you know is there
yeah talk a little bit about the earned
income tax credit and some of the other
tax policies that have been tried that
are you know considered uh child
friendly or family friendly and do they
have the the effects the the intended
effects or is it mostly kind of
rewarding people for decisions that they
were going to do anyway
yeah I don't know if good research
um that that shows uh that they have
moved the needle you know in terms of
people that would have people that
wanted to have another child
um being you know uh incentivizing them
to have more kids I think you know the
child tax credit is
uh something that goes pretty high up
the income scale so you can be a married
couple making four hundred thousand
dollars a year and still get the maximum
child tax credit uh for per child
um I I think there probably are some
families you know that switched from
being two worker families to being uh
one worker families and having having
one of the parents stay at home
um that's a that's a sort of explicit
goal that a lot of social conservatives
have for the program I think
um but I I've not seen any evidence to
suggest that it's affected fertility
um the eitc the earned income tax credit
that you mentioned is more of an
anti-poverty program than the child tax
credit is um it phases out a lot sooner
it's targeted much more towards the
Working Poor
um and I I don't know a good evidence
there that that is also increased
fertility but it does sort of raise I
think what ought to be a real concern
for a lot of the pronatalists um who
generally think that these incentives
are going to increase uh the number of
kids being raised by Mary Perry and
maybe it's going to increase the number
of kids and married parent families with
one parent at home
but to the extent that they target folks
lower down on the income ladder they
could also increase fertility uh in ways
that maybe they haven't thought about
non-marital fertility unintended
fertility
teen fertility
it really raises the question of of is
all fertility something that we want to
encourage the pulse he wants to
encourage and it's really relevant
there's good research showing that the
decline in fertility since the Great
Recession is overwhelmingly a decline in
non-marital fertility so it's it's not
that married couples are having fewer
kids it's that single single mothers are
having fewer kids
um over half of it is a decline in
unintended fertility
um so do we wish that we had had more uh
unintended births since since 2007.
that's a big open question that's a
fascinating kind of question too of like
you know one of the ways you know if you
uh you know to paraphrase Willie Sutton
who you know rob banks because that's
where the money is do you want to go
back to a world in which uh teenagers
are having more kids because
way down that's
yeah it's such a Triumph I mean I think
until about 1970 that it was typical
that you know a first live birth was to
a woman who was 20 or younger
um that has aged up and it also seems
particularly with social conservatives
who are often obsessed with you know
issues of grooming and things like that
we have effectively desexualized
adolescence and young adulthood or or
late teen years
um which would seem to be a win but then
it's like okay well you know why aren't
kids having more sex or more births it
it gets confusing
um very quickly that's part of the live
stream conversation that I had with
Scott Winship of the American Enterprise
Institute and Elizabeth Nolan Brown of
Reason talking about whether or not the
state should encourage people to have
more babies if you want to see the full
conversation go here if you want to see
another segment go here